actor Robert De Niro you may have seen
this is in the middle of a lawsuit
against a former assistant who
binge-watched fifty five episodes of
friends in four days while on the job
so he's suing the assistant fifty five
episodes of friends in four days while
at work that seems like a lot but then I
thought to myself I know someone who
could blow that number away someone who
watches a lot of television at work has
for the 10 years she's worked for me
I'm talking about my assistant Sona
obsess young now Monday on the show I
challenge Sona to beat the record of 55
episodes in four days with it before I
could finish the sentence she said no
problem and she's been watching friends
at work since then her performance at
work has been horrible but her
performance watching friends has been
inspirational here are some of the
highlights
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry I don't usually laugh this much at
work
let you're on my side on this one anyway
ladies I'm in Sona finished watching
friends just before we started taping
tonight I was just handed the results
here they are Robert De Niro's assistant
watched 55 episodes in four days while
at work my assistant Sona watched get
this 58 episodes of Frank the new world
record holder for watching friends
episodes at work
recoil lightly on the shoulder and you
were coiled as if I were an evil man
Sona this is very exciting how are you
feeling about this accomplishment I feel
really great I'm very proud of myself
one of the top accomplishments in my
life yeah okay I work really hard for it
you worked very yeah okay what was it
like when you actually finished episode
58 what was that feeling I don't know
what to describe it to it might be I
don't know I just I felt like I had
finally done something with my life yeah
okay favorite episode you have a
favorite episode of all those episodes
you watch ah you know I started back
when they were at the beach house and
that was and so that was the end of
season 3 now I made it all the way to
season 6 yeah and Monica and Chandler
just moved in together so there's a lot
that happened it's very hard to pick
with C this isn't breaking news
that happened like 12 years ago hey
Gilligan got off the island I mean what
are we talking about here
God say well you know what this is an
accomplishment this is a big deal put
the challenge to you and you did it so
you deserve some prizes I think yeah
persona I personally got you copies of
all the friends episodes you watch
digitally but I got them for you on VHS
[Applause]
really well do you have a VHS player I
do not have a chess player there at yard
sales also because I know you a one
month supply of marijuana edibles Ronnie
no no no no not now not now not now have
you ever had an edible while you were
working for me be honest I
I really like this gift all right Beacon
Theatre New York okay I've never seen
you more confused and finally I am
giving you Sona six puppies named Rachel
Monica
[Applause]
[Music]
right hey Joey there's a Phoebe there's
a channel one one for each member the
cows and your because we spent no money
putting the names on the puppies
congratulations Sona we have a great
show tonight from the ABC series Grand
Hotel Eva Longoria is here
[Music]
[Applause]